bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce fil rouge sur la paléo
neurologie on continue notre fil rouge
de l'été sauf que cette fois je vais
vous laisser pour les trois ou quatre
prochaines vidéos avec le docteur
raffaella dont un spécialiste de la
taphonomie alors la taphonomie qu'est ce
que c'est c'est la science de comment
les choses deviennent des fossiles vous
m'avez entendue par exemple répété
maintes et maintes fois dans plein de
vidéos différentes que c'est pas parce
qu'on retrouve plusieurs squelettes
fossilisés ensemble que ça veut dire que
les animaux qui ont produit ces
squelettes ont vécu ensemble d'ailleurs
ça ne veut même pas dire qu'ils sont
morts ensemble ça pourrait être une
simple coïncidence ça pourrait être une
rivière qui les a qui les a rassemblés
donc il ya plein de raisons pour
laquelle plusieurs squelettes pourrait
se retrouver ensemble et c'est la
taphonomie c'est l'étude en fait de
l'environnement de dépôt et de la façon
dont ces squelettes se sont trouvés
réunis qui va nous dire si oui ou non on
peut interpréter un la présence de
squelettes ensemble comme à part ayant
appartenu à des animaux qui ont vécu
ensemble donc raffaella non le docteur
raffaella nom est un spécialiste de
cette discipline qu'on appelle la
taphonomie et je vous laisse avec lui
profitez-en bien à plus tard ok bonjour
à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce cours d'introduction à la
taphonomie
alors tout d'abord je tenais à remercier
julien benoît pour me laisser
l'opportunité de donner
secours introductif sur sa chaîne en
traction
c'est une super opportunité pour moi de
faire connaître ma discipline mais aussi
de tout simplement
m'entraîner à communiquer
hors de cette discipline qui est souvent
méconnu du grand public
j'aimerais également me présenter
d'abord parce que c'est vrai que c'est
la première fois il me semble que que
j'apparais là sur la chaîne donc pas
bonjour à toutes et à tous
je suis le docteur a fait là non donc
moi je suis
chercheur post doctorant à l'université
du vide batteur se rendent à
johannesbourg en afrique du sud
j'ai obtenu une thèse de doctorat du
muséum national d'histoire naturelle de
paris en 2019
et moi je m'intéresse principalement
ici en afrique du sud et en afrique
australe en général à
l'évolution du régime alimentaire et des
comportements de subsistance on va le
voir un peu pendant ce court
chez les home in in un peu tout au long
de leur histoire évolutive mais
principalement nous allons devoir
pendant une période cruciale
de l'évolution
de la lignée humaine qui est le pli au
pléistocène
donc
ce cours il va être divisé en deux en
deux grandes parties
je vais d'abord moi vous présenter
des défis sion définition de ce qu'est
la taphonomie définition de ce qu'elle
plaide le pli au pléistocène nous
verrons un peu aussi un peu d'histoire
et d'historiques de cette discipline en
afrique principalement
un peu de méthode de méthodologie de
concept pour un peu comprendre ce qui se
fait en ce moment ça ce sera la première
partie et ensuite dans une autre vidéo
dans une deuxième partie
je vous présenterai des études de cas
des exemples un peu plus un peu plus
concret de ce qui se fait en ce moment
et de ce qui est débattue en taphonomie
je vous présenterai
des sites en particulier
en afrique toujours dans le verra mais
on restera concentrée sur l'afrique
donc des sites puis au pléistocène
africains pour lesquels les données ou
plutôt l'interprétation des données ne
fait pas vraiment consensus dans la dans
la communauté scientifique et on verra
pourquoi est normalement en ayant vu la
première vidéo cette première partie
vous serez capable d'avoir en tout cas
une grille de lecture pour essayer de
comprendre où se situe exactement ces
débats ok
donc commencer suite par
un peu de disions
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que la
taphonomie alors la taphonomie
ça a été inventé en 1940 par un
paléontologue russe du nom divin efremov
qui était également
écrivains de fiction donc peut-être
certains d'entre vous
le connaissent déjà comme à travers ses
écrits de science fiction
mais il est avant tout un paléontologue
et
et il a
était une influence majeure dans la
paléontologie moderne parce qu'il a dans
une de ses publications 1940 défini ce
nouveau terme
qu'est la taphonomie qui est en fin de
compte étymologiquement la racine du mot
taphonomie elle vient de la contraction
de deux mots du grec ancien qui est à
fos qui veut dire
l'enfouissement burion donc
l'enfouissement de quelque chose et
nomos dons qui sont les lois en général
donc
étymologie vivement ce terme signifie
les lois de l'enfouissement la
taphonomie c'est ça c'est l'étude de ce
qu'on peut parfois appelé les phénomènes
de fossilisation mais pas que et on le
verra
ce serait un peu réducteur de limiter la
taphonomie a simplement des processus de
fossilisation verra que c'est pas le cas
en tout cas pas dans la définition
moderne du t1
donc
c'est ivan romeuf ce paléontologue russe
en 1940 qu'a défini
ce terrain
alors il faut savoir je vais pas revenir
sur toute l'histoire de la taphonomie
1940 c'est l'invention du terme mais il
faut savoir que la taphonomie exister
par essence bien avant la définition
même du mot
notamment en médecine légale ce qu'on
appelle à l'afrique
et on a des exemples très tôt même 2,2
de léonard de vinci qui appliquaient des
des principes paléontologique et
économique
pour démontrer
l'existence
pommard en europe voilà donc je vais pas
trop détaillé là dessus il ya de la
littérature là dessus sur l'histoire de
de la taphonomie on a pas mal donc si
vous êtes intéressé un peu par sa vous
pouvez aller voir plus tôt
voilà donc les lois de l'enfouissement
il faut savoir que la définition
d'origine donné par paref romoff c'était
que la taphonomie c'est l'étude de la
transition
des restes d'animaux
de la biosphère à la lithosphère ou
qu'est ce que ça veut dire la biosphère
c'est
toute la dimension vivante d'un
écosystème
tandis que la litho la lithosphère
c'est toute la dimension minérales non
biologique d'un environnement ou d'un
écosystème et lui ce qu'il dit efremov
c'est que
la taphonomie c'est l'étude de la
transition d'un animal vers le monde
minéral ce qu on pourrait comprendre par
fossilisation
un phénomène de fossilisation
mais on va le voir que pendant cette ce
processus pendant cette transition
beaucoup d'événements
peuvent se produire et tout ça on va le
développer par la suite
il faut savoir aujourd'hui la définition
est un peu changé et c'est un peu étendu
et aujourd'hui c'est plutôt
la taphonomie
l'étude de la transition d'une forme
vivante et pas que d'un animal
l'étude de là
de sa forme vivante à sa mort jusqu'à sa
découverte ce serait plus aujourd'hui la
définition moderne qu'est ce que ça
change ça change que
forme vivante ça ne réduit pas ça ne
réduit plus seulement la taphonomie à
l'étude des restes d'animaux
mais ça englobe également
tout autre type de
de bio art fact que ça peut être donc ça
peut être des plantes ça peut être des
ossements d'animaux effectivement mais
aussi des invertébrés
et tout ça et pas forcément que des
animaux vertébrés
on pourrait imaginer dans le sens commun
et ensuite
intéresse ce n'est pas seulement
compte comment ils s'effacent hills et
comment il est deux comment il est
devenu par du monde minéral mais s'est
également essayé de comprendre tout ce
qui s'est passé entre la fin de vie
vante l'état vivant l'état de mort et
l'état de découvertes par la suite tout
ce qui peut se passer
entre eux étape qu'est ce que c'est
fille ça signifie que vous prenez on va
rester sur le cas classique
d'une forme animale vivante un animal
vivant
au lapin dont
un animal vivant il peut il va un moment
de sa vie
subir ce changement d'état qui est la
mort et ça ça peut arriver de
différentes façons que ce soit de
manière naturelle dit naturel entre
guillemets donc ça peut être par un
événement catastrophique
pour exemple simplement une éruption
volcanique coulées de lave
une montée des eaux noyade un animal qui
ce qui qui s'embourbe et qui ce qui se
noie où c'est ouf ça peut également et
c'est souvent une des causes majeures
que qu'on retrouve nous en tout cas dans
les sites paléontologiques
archéologiques
par prédation l'abord par prédation un
carnivore va
abattre un animal et voilà donc c'est
une des causes principales de morts mais
il ya également babolat les maladies
c'est un
an suite
vous en doutez ce cadavre de
ne s'arrête pas de vivre à ce moment là
il a une histoire très très longue il va
avoir une histoire très très longue
après sa mort ce corps continuent
d'avoir une histoire notamment par
l'arrivée
d'espèces qui vont se nourrir de ce2 de
ce corps que ce soit les carnivores mais
aussi eu les insectes les oiseaux donc
par chat rognage ou simplement après
avoir abattu l'animal simplement
voilà le carnivore se nourrit de cette
carcasse
ensuite une fois que toute trace
de viande disparaît une fois que
l'animal n'a plus une fois que la
carcasse n'a plus d'intérêt aux yeux
d'autres formes vivantes
il reste malgré tout
des eaux des parties du squelette qui
sont encore en place qui sont encore là
à l'air libre et qui peuvent être
déplacées
soit par piétinement par exemple ça peut
arriver si
de nombreux individus admettons
de bovidés des antilopes qui prennent
chaque année le même couloir migratoire
si plusieurs individus meurent à cet
endroit et que l'année d'après le
couloir migratoire est réutilisé
que un effet de piétinement
impact cette carcasse de l'année
précédente et déplace les eaux les
fractures
les explose
et les déplace sur tout mais pas que par
piétinement et fait forcément le
déplacement et l'altération d'une
carcasse
[Musique]
et peu à et par
le nombre bien que ce soit également
découler terrain
l'érosion tout bêtement
ou encore une inondation qui peut très
facilement
déplacer des ossements
en parle ah
le déplacement le piétinement tout ça ça
peut être mixé par des effets
d'altération climatiques qu'on appelle
l'un temporisation en français et en
anglais qui en fait
la libération des ossements à la suite
de des variations climatiques nous ça va
être variations d'humidité
variations en température en exposition
du soleil par exemple en préhistoire
européenne pour la préhistoire un peu
plus récentes
sur des sites à homo sapiens du
paléolithique supérieur par exemple là
où on a
les cycles glaciaires qui sont déjà bien
installés
on a des phénomènes qu'on va appeler de
2,2 g l'effraction qui va être en fête
l'altération gel dégel qui va pouvoir
avoir un effet parfois assez destructeur
sur les ossements
car ça va
force est l'os à
aso à se
rétracter
et ensuite à parfois explosé sous
l'effet du gel et du dégel
une fois que tout ça est fait on peut
également avoir d'ailleurs c'est même
pas forcément après tout c'est tout tous
ces phénomènes peuvent être
s'alterner il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
d'ordre
spécifique assez
assez demain
on peut
parce que les racines des plantes sont
très acide est très mauvaise pour la
conservation des eaux et à peuvent
facilement altérée ces fossiles et on a
également toutes formes vivantes comme
les rongeurs qui est beaucoup on va le
voir après qui aime beaucoup rongé les
eaux les déplacés les emmener dans leurs
dans leur petit chez soi
ça leur permet comme les rougeurs vous
savez probablement non décisive à
croissance continue ça leur permet en
fait eu
dabra zeller dans de manière assez
naturelle en utilisant les ou
comme pierre ponce quoi concrètement
une fois que ces ossements sont
enfuis on à l'arrivée des altérations
géologique donc là ça va être tout ce
qui est d'ordre également et dia
génétique tout ça donc je vais pas
entrer trop dans les détails nous pas
avoir des altérations au niveau
moléculaire de l'os et on va avoir des
processus comme celui de la
fossilisation donc il va à pied peut
dire un dur et lens pour qu'ils
deviennent même de la pierre qu'on
pourrait appeler de la pierre mais on a
d'autres phénomènes qui peuvent être par
exemple la compression la compression
sédimentaires c'est à dire quand un
haussement se retrouve coincé
sous une autre séquence stratigraphique
et que le poids de ces sédiments vont
venir compresser les fossiles et parfois
les fractures et
enfin bas à l'érosion et la découverte
parce que c'est souvent grâce à
l'érosion qu'on va découvrir un
d'affleurements
géologique d'une couche géologique et
qu'on va être en mesure de découvrir un
assemblage faut s'y faire
voilà et l'érosion peut également
conduire à des modifications des
carcasses donc tout ça
tous ces phénomènes l'a compris sion de
l'interaction de tous ces phénomènes
c'est ce qu'on a la taphonomie c'est
l'étude de la transition d'un animal
vivant jusqu'à sa découverte donc ça
demande une
vue d'ensemble
une vue assez général
de comment fonctionne un écosystème
pour essayer de deux d'appréhender tous
ces phénomènes et pourquoi faire ça
parce qu'en fait essayer de de
reconstruire et de comprendre tous ces
phénomènes ça va nous permettre
d'obtenir des informations
sur le contexte écologique d'origine du
dépôt mais également sur les différents
billets qui peuvent impacter
[Musique]
l'enregistrement fossiles
par exemple on va prendre un exemple
donc on va prendre exemple d'un
écosystème
donc vous avez votre food d'origine
votre faute originelle
qui va se déposer un endroit et qui va
devenir votre site paléontologique ou
archéologique
équivalent
autre
accumulation osseuse d'origine
la différence entre
ce que ce qu'est un dépôt au ce
et la faune qui habite dans l'écosystème
dans lequel se dépose aux ossements il
peut être influencé par pas mal de biais
tout d'abord par une sélection
assez parfois assez précise
une sélection des espèces selon l'agent
accumulateurs d'origine par exemple les
lions les léopards et les hyènes n'ont
pas les mêmes habitudes alem alimentaire
il ne chasse pas forcément les mêmes
proies
et c'est ce qui fait que une
accumulation
d'ossements qui a été accumulée par un
lion un léopard un guépard ou une hyène
ou un homme seront
de fait nature différente même si
ils habitent dans le même écosystème
et 6 ans ça
qu'on peut avoir d'ores et déjà
un biais dans la représentativité de
votre assemblage eu
ensuite une fois que vous avez gelé trop
vite une fois que vous avez votre votre
votre accumulation
osseuse
vous pouvez avoir tout un tas comme je
voulais présenter juste avant tout un
tas de modifications qui peuvent
impacter
le cet assemblage par exemple comme je
lé deal intempéries nation donc
l'alternance des différents facteurs
climatiques mais aussi l'effet de de
calcification des calcifications d'un
dépôt donc c'est quand un dépôt 20
vacins durée
la compaction sédimentaires l'érosion
etc etc tous et ses modifications qu'on
a vu juste avant et ça ça va conduire à
la disparition de certaines votre pièce
osseuse certaines pièces très fragiles
vont disparaître les individus
qui étaient plus jeunes les juvéniles
qui ont des ossatures un peu plus
fragiles que leurs compères adultes ils
vont disparaître beaucoup plus
rapidement que les adultes ce qui va
vous induire un biais dans votre
assemblage à ce niveau là ok
et ensuite quand vous vous étiez cet
assemblage au ce vous pouvez vous même
induire des biais dans votre étude
que ce soit par le protocole
méthodologiques que vous avez mis en
place et qui va peut-être pas forcément
être assez exhaustif et donc vous allez
pouvoir peut-être loupé certaines
informations
la grave mais ça arrive
que ce soit géologie en paléontologie ou
en archéologie arts des billets majeur
qui arrive
régulièrement c'est l'expérience
personnelle des chercheurs parce que ce
sont des sciences qui sont
par nature empirique c'est à dire basé
sur l'observation et l'expérience
donc
plus on a vu plus on n'a d'expérience
en théorie meilleur on est ok donc
parce que plus on a vu deux phénomènes
différents deux phénomènes la photonique
et de processus taphonomie différents à
travers tout tous types d'écosystèmes
tous types de biomasse et tous types de
dépôts sédimentaires meilleur on sera
pour les identifier donc c'est assez
voilà et en sus et ensuite bien sûr les
connaissances actuelles qui peuvent
influencer vos interprétations parce que
vous pouvez être amené à ne pas
comprendre un phénomène tout simplement
parce qu'il n'a jamais été observé
et tout ça
c'est ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui ce
qu'on appelle la taphonomie c'est à dire
essayer de comprendre chaque filtre à
chaque étape de l'histoire de votre
assemblage aussi
essayer de comprendre
ces filtres et et tous ces phénomènes
comment ils interagissent roach entre
eux et c'est ce qui va permettre de
mieux comprendre
les conditions de dépôt d'origine de
votre assemblage et ainsi vous
permettent sans trop de bié essayer
d'interpréter en terme de comportement
tous les toutes les observations que
vous avez sur les carnivores sur les
zones sûres des homininés etc etc
ok ce sera peut-être un peu plus clair
par la suite de toute façon on va
détailler tout ça ensemble donc vous
savez à peu près maintenant ce qu'est la
taphonomie 1
c'est un peu
le trait général c'est très vaste
la taphonomie et moi je vais vous
présenter uniquement
l'application de la taphonomie à un
contexte qui est très particulier qui
est le pli au pléistocène en afrique
donc est ce que c'est
un peu de contexte
alors le pli au pléistocène
il faut savoir que c'est un terme qui
est pas mal usitée dans la bibliographie
c'est pas mal lu cité par la communauté
des prix storia
surtout africaniste mais il faut savoir
que
[Musique]
officiellement ce terme n'est pas
reconnue par la chatte pratique par la
nomenclature la charte stratigraphique
internationale qui a une visée
universelle bien qu' elle ne l'est pas
forcément
[Musique]
donc si on reprend 7 cette nomenclature
stratigraphique
nous on va se situer dans une période
donc la période qui nous intéresse elle
va se situer à la jonction entre le
pliocène donc le pliocène
c'est une période qui va de 5,3 à 2,6
millions d'années sa 7e
et
le pléistocène
en tout cas les deux premiers
stades du pléistocène que sont le
gymnasien entre 2 608 millions d'années
et le calabria entre 1,8 million
d'années et 780 mille ans
ok
le cheylas siens et le cas là brillant
du prix storia
on a plutôt l'habitude de lait
par facilité par habitude de l'est de
les associer ensemble et 2 nommé plis
stoessel inférieur donc le gymnasien et
le cal à briançon en général d'aubay
pléistocène inférieur
donc le pli au pléistocène
ça va être doux une période qu'on va
plutôt si tu es un tout petit peu avant
la transition clio simpliste celles
inférieures donc un peu au milieu du
piage anciens aux alentours trois
millions d'années et on va pousser ça
jusqu'à un petit peu
avant la fin du pléistocène inférieur au
milieu du canadien jusqu'à un million
d'années donc en général quand on parle
de prix ou police de seine ont fait
référence à une période qui se situe
entre 3 et 1 1 million d'années bien
qu'il n'y a pas de définition
stricte de ce que représente cette
période
parce qu'elle n'est pas
il faut comprendre que le plie aux
pistes celle n'a pas de réalité
géologique c'est une c'est une période
qui a été plutôt utilisé
pour faciliter doux
de comparaison lorsque l'on travaille
sur sur ses sites entre 3 et 1 million
d'années
voilà mais ce qu'il dit ce qui est
surtout intéressant important de redire
c'est la transition entre le pléistocène
et le pliocène c'est ça notre au final
notre événement clé c'est ça qui nous
intéresse le plus hot list scène c'est
étudié tout ce qu'il ya autour de cette
transition finale cette transition a
lieu à 2,6 points 58 millions d'années
alors pourquoi cette période en part
culié pourquoi est ce qu'elle nous
intéresse et pourquoi en afrique
donc
si vous regardez cette chaîne et si vous
regardez secours je pense que vous êtes
déjà un petit peu intéressés par
l'évolution humaine donc je pense que
que vous savez que dans le registre
fossile l'évolution humaine et remonte
au moins jusqu'à 7 ou 6 millions
d'années donc il y avait déjà une longue
histoire de l'évolution humaine à 20
alors pourquoi 3 et 1 million d'années
nous intéresse en particulier parce que
à cette période
entre le pliocène help liste scène se
passe de nombreux changements majeurs
au sein du registre fossile
et août cette transition à 2,6 millions
d'amis
tout d'abord
au cours du
inférieur on à l'apparition au sein du
registre fossile des plus anciennes
traces
de boucherie
surhaussement de grands mammifères
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'est ce que
ça implique c'est la première trace
directe
d'une consommation de viande
par les aux mines
voilà et ça c'est un phénomène qui nous
intéresse
beaucoup quand on étudie l'évolution
humaine c'est essayer de comprendre
quand comment et pourquoi les eaux
minier donc commencé à consommer de la
viande
est donc ça arrive aux alentours de 3 4
millions d'années bien que ces traces et
nous le verrons dans la deuxième partie
de secours parce que je vais développer
ce cas à ses caractéristiques et
les plus anciennes traces de découpe sur
le site de dickie qu'at
elle de fonds consensus ses marques tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord sur leur
identification en tant que marque de
boucherie voilà ça on en parlera dans la
deuxième vidéo
toujours aux alentours de 3,4 3,3
millions d'années on à l'apparition des
plus anciennes industries lithiques et
plus anciens outils en pierre qui ont
été définies en 2015
le lobait klein c'est comme ça que ce
noble dans cette nouvelle industrie qui
fait également aujourd'hui débat tous
les chercheurs ne sont pas d'accord sur
non pas l'identification de ces outils
en tant que tel mais plutôt sur
mais plutôt sur l'intégrité
des couches sédimentaires des couches
géologiques dons proviennent ces restes
passer ces outils là
tous d'accord lâche
ensuite entre 2,8
2,4 millions d'années on a un changement
majeur qui se produit un changement
climatique majeur qui est dû en fait
donc je ne vais pas rentrer dans les
détails parce que d'une part ce n'est
pas ma spécialité
j'aurais peur de dire des bêtises et
d'autre part parce que c'est bien trop
complexe pour être détaillés ici c'est
pas l'objet du coup il ya 2,6 millions
d'années s'opère un changement dans les
paramètres astronomiques
de la terre et notamment de
l'excentricité de son orbite autour du
soleil et c'est ce qui va induire des
changements climatiques et notamment
l'arrivée d'un phénomène d'acidification
majeur
sur le globe
qui va conduire
recul progressif des forêts
tropicales qui vont se concentrer autour
de l'équateur et au développement
majeur
d'environnement de type prairies ou
savane
c'est à dire heureusement ouvert et sec
riche en graminées
et ce phénomène
climatique majeur qui marque l'entrée
dans le pléistocène mais également dans
l'ère quaternaire
et vassas allier forcément d'un
changement dans la composition des faux
les faux devoir répondre à cet événement
climatique en s'adaptant
et on va avoir
l'apparition de deux taxes ou plutôt
adapté à des milieux arides
ce qui n'était pas cas auparavant ok
ensuite toujours aux cours de se plier
au pléistocène tison doux
pour va l'apparition des plus anciens
outils en main cette fois ci
aux alentours
2,2 2,3 millions d'années en afrique du
sud on va parler aussi un petit peu et
le centre dans la deuxième partie de ce
coût
voilà donc des outils en hausse
b ce qui est intéressant
c'est que
en même temps tout autour ce pied au
christ aux scènes on va
pas de manière récurrente mais en tous
cas de manière assez
commune pour le noter la présence de
marques de carnivores sur les restes
fossiles d'homininés eux mêmes ce qui
montre que de fait que les hobbies dean
avait un statut probablement un peu
bâtard entre chasseurs et chasser
c'est là où se situe tout notre question
taphonomie au cours du clip liste sept
cessé de reconstruire la place qu'avait
les aux minimes
au sein de leur écosystème et essayer d'
un peu plus comprendre
ce glissement
qui s'est produit à un moment donné de
notre histoire évolutive entre eux trois
et chasseurs hyper hyper prédateurs des
zones où
à quel moment s'est effectué ce
glissement pourquoi et surtout avec qui
parce que au cours de cette période
nous n'a l'habitude
d'être les seuls
au biel il est sur terre nous sommes les
seuls représentants de de notre genre au
bo nous sommes là nous sommes la seule
espèce représentante de notre genre
aujourd'hui et il n'existe pas d'autres
genres
2010 aujourd'hui sur la planète ce
n'était bien entendu pas le cas
au cours du plie aux pistes cède
et encore moi j'ai envie de dire au
cours du pied au pistolet basse que
cette période elle est
réputée pour
son explosion en termes de diversité
chez les minimes on va avoir notamment
pendant cette période des restes de
l'australopithèque donc
australopithecus d'eau bien sûr vous
avez tous entendu parler
de lui si tu squelette de lucy
donc voilà à savoir qu'il ya qu'il y
avait à cette époque là plusieurs espèce
d'australopithèque
qui étaient contemporains ou disons sub
contemporain
on va avoir également au cours de cette
période l'apparition des premiers
représentants de notre genre le genre
togo donc les premiers représentants du
genre humain
on va plutôt les définir comme ça
premier représentant du genre humain
parce qu'en fait la taxinomie
des premiers représentants du genre
humain on va pas se le cacher c'est le
bazar il ya énormément de groupes et de
fossiles
qui ne match pas entre eux c'est ce
qu'on appelle des groupes para fils
éthique donc ça de toute façon si vous
êtes un habitué de la chaîne je vous
conseille d'aller plutôt voir des courts
de julien là dessus des cours de
paléontologie mais voilà
australopithèques us et d'un genre par
affi l'éthique
et enfin on va avoir également part
entre opus l'apparition et la
disparition du genre part en europe au
cours de cette période du plie aux
pistes scène et toute notre question ici
est de savoir
qui a pour la première fois consommé de
la viande
comment est-ce que c'était par
charognards donc c'est à dire par
opportunisme
tout simplement ou par chasse
ou par la rogne âge actif la différence
on va parler il semble après b donc
charronnage passif et charognards active
donc le charognard passif ça va être
plutôt passé après les carnivores quand
il reste un peu pas grand chose a bougé
on passe après et on gratte un peu ce
qui reste le charognard actifs au
contraire ça va être plutôt suivre
activement et intentionnellement les
groupes de carnivores mais ces groupes
de carnivores vont abattre une proie et
ensuite à nous de faire le boulot de
faire fuir ces carnivores pour avoir
accès à une carcasse toute fraîche sans
être trop foulés
voilà ça c'est le chat rognage le passif
donc voilà donc tout notre question ici
à se situe sur les comportements de
subsistance c'est à dire les
comportements alimentaires les
comportements cynégétique comment ces
espèces avaient accès à la viande
de quelle manière
et quelle était la variabilité de leur
régime alimentaire ça c'est très
important pour nous pour essayer de
comprendre un peu plus les mécanismes de
l'évolution humaine qui sont
sous-jacents essaie de comprendre un peu
les mécanismes qui sont à l'oeuvre
derrière est ce que le régime
alimentaire a été un mécanisme majeur de
l'évolution humaine comme ça a été dit
auparavant notamment dans les années 90
où le paradigme
majeur le paradigme scientifique majeure
était que
la consommation de la viande a perdi
permis donc elle a encouragé ou est un
mécanisme si long que c'est un mécanisme
qui qui qui avaient été proposées
en étant en gros à l'origine de
l'encéphale isation c'est à dire du
développement du cerveau tout au long de
l'allier mais voilà je vous le
joug le le résume très brièvement c'est
ça c'est en gros dans les années 90 et
un papier qui est sorti dans des
lectures de aiello et
j'ai oublié le député et moteur vous
m'excuserez qui pose qui qui proposait
cette hypothèse cette idée selon
laquelle
un changement du régime alimentaire
couplée à une bipédie
effective avait permis une réduction
progressive
de l'appareil digestif
et s'accoupler avec un régime
alimentaire riche en protéines avait
permis de développer le cerveau
aujourd'hui cette hypothèse les remises
en question par beaucoup de travaux
notamment sur deux groupes de primates
non humains qui tendent à prouver que
en tout cas si cette hypothèse
est la vraie
chez l'être humain ce n'est pas le cas
pour tous les autres groupes donc
pourquoi voilà donc ça c'est une
question qui reste encore en suspens
n'est pas encore bien
calés là dessus on sait pas encore bien
qu'elle allait qu'elle a été exactement
le rôle du régime alimentaire et
notamment de la viande au sein du régime
alimentaire donc ça s'est un peu
enfin non du régime alimentaire sain
d'évolution humaine ça c'est encore tout
un débat
d'autant plus que
au cours dû plier liste scène la majeure
partie
de nos sites sur lesquels nous
travaillons
sont concentrés
dans deux régions majeures de l'afrique
que sont l'afrique du sud donc l'afrique
australe les disons l'afrique du sud en
général parce qu'en vrai
en sortant d'afrique du sud en afrique
australe ya pas grand chose et l'afrique
de l'est
donc l'afrique de l'est cela pour le
coup ça va être principal beau ethiopie
avec la vallée de l'omo bien sûr le
kenya avec le bassin du turkana
évidemment et la tanzanie avec les
gorges d'olduvai évidemment
aussi
il faut savoir que
tous les sites concentrés
dans ces docks qui sont concentrés dans
ces régions ils ont des dépôts des
contextes de dépôts sédimentaires qui
varient et qui diffère
en afrique du sud par exemple nous on
travaille principalement sur des sites
en grotte
qui ne possède plus ou qu'ils ne
possèdent pas disons de stratigraphie
verticale très clair on pas rentrer dans
les détails parce que ce n'est pas non
plus un cours de sédimentologie et de
karstologie et
il faut savoir que
l'alternance
de phénomènes et de processus de
décalcification et de calcification sur
des dépôts en grottes suivi de l'érosion
de ses dépôts va conduire parfois pardon
à
l'érosion tout simplement de la lecture
stratigraphique
ça nous empêche parfois de lire
correctement mais également d' inversion
stratigraphique ou parfois une poche
peut se créer au sein d'un dépôt dans
lequel va se redéposer un dépôt plus
jeunes à l'intérieur d'un dépôt plus
anciens du coup là on va avoir des
phénomène d'inversion de stratégie et ça
c'est un problème pour nous ce qui est
complètement différent
des sites d'afrique de l'est africain ou
là pour le coup
et c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu énormément
de développement de travaux de pas photo
by et de ta faute de préhistoire au
général en afrique de l'est c'est que
eux ils ont des dépôts à la lecture
beaucoup plus claires ou en tout cas qui
plus facile à calais
notamment parce que ce sont des dépôts
de type
fluviatile qui vont
saleté les entre des dépôts
volcaniques
et ça pour nous c'est super parce que
les dépôts volcaniques sasso dax super
bien et quand on a une stratégie assez
clair et assez longue
d'alternance de dépôt fluviatile et de
grosses croûte volcaniques s'est dit
qu'elle parce que on a juste à dater
concrètement les couches de jets d'oise
et on al'âge de
du chocolat qui entre les deux
concrètement c'est ça ça fonctionne
comme un gâteau à étages
c'est pas forcément ce qu'on a nous dans
les grottes en afrique du sud
voilà où nous note datation et va
principalement être passé sur les spéléo
thème donc tout ce qui est formation
chalcidique donc
stalagmites stalactites
qui vont se former
sur les dépôts b mais voilà donc et ça
c'est tout un autre monde et tout un de
tes pas lâcher ou chronologie
garder en tête que c'est très complexe
l'afrique du sud les dépôts
sédimentaires se sont très compliquées
et c'est ce qui parfois nous empêche de
faire de la comparaison directe entre
les deux dès qu on a dû en afrique du
sud avec les sites d'afrique de l'est
donc c'est une autre difficulté qui se
rajoute
à tous nos billets lorsque l'on fait une
analyse graphologique
ok
voilà un peu pour ce qui est de la
définition je vais essayer peut-être
d'aller un peu plus vite sur le reste
parce que là je remarque que j'ai déjà
parlé longtemps
sur les définitions donc un peu
d'historique pour essayer un peu que
vous compreniez un peu plus toustou
cheminement qui nous a conduit à la
situation dans laquelle on est à l'heure
actuelle
commençons par l'afrique du sud parce
que c'est d'une part su ce que je
connais le mieux mais aussi parce que ça
va être notre point de départ ça va être
notre point de départ
de manière chronologique pourquoi parce
que il faut savoir que
australopithecus a été découvert pour la
première fois en afrique du sud en 1924
par
et publié en 1925
par raymond arthur d'arte donc qui était
un anatomiste australien qui est venu
à johannesbourg dans les années 20
pour prendre la position de professeur
d'anatomie de la toute nouvelle
fraîchement ouverte et inauguré
d'université du vite vincent
donc lui il a découvert et décrit le
produit reste d'australopithèques donc
bon je vais pas vous refaire un peu
toute l'histoire cas derrière mais c'est
l'histoire qui est extrêmement
intéressante parce que à l'époque 1925
il faut se rendre compte que
le bond de scientifiques et encore
persuadé que l'origine de l'homme se
situant d'europe notamment à cause du
fossile de deux piles darde qui s'était
avec s'est avéré par la suite être un
faux
et tout ça sûrement que julien vous en
parle
sur sa chaîne
bref c'est une histoire
extrêmement extrêmement intéressante
pour l'histoire des sciences
lui répond arthur date a été le premier
à essayer de démontrer preuves à l'appui
que charles darwin avait raison et que
l'origine de l'homme se trouve
effectivement bien en afrique voilà sa
grâce à la découverte de ce sera au
pique nique
500 en 1925 par la suite lui il va ex
rivale eva saint denis va énormément
s'intéresser un australopithèque us et
dota mans à cobo il vivait et pour ça il
sait bien en tête pour étudier d
assemblage au ceux qui ont été retrouvés
avec australopithèques dans deux grottes
d'afrique du sud que son tang et bakar
en ce cas
et c'est ce qui va plus est de
développer
son hypothèse du singe tueur à kyle à
aleppo thesis qui leur est pas voté
pour lui
tous ces ossements
qui ont été retrouvés avec
australopithèques ont été accumulées par
australopithèques
lui pensé également que beaucoup des
fossiles qu'il retrouvait dans ces
grottes était en fin de compte des
outils en os utilisé par
australopithèque
et c'est ce qu'il a fini par définir
comme étant la culture ostéo d'autocars
atik
un beau
un peu compliqué pour dire tout
simplement
aux stéroïdes socratique culture qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire tout
simplement la culture en dos pendant et
en caraty
ce que lui pensait que les
australopithèques utiliser
les ossements des animaux mais aussi
leurs dents parfois leurs mandibules
comme couteau mais aussi leur kératine
c'est à dire les ongles et les cornes
comme vous pouvez voir sur ces images en
bas là comme outil
voilà donc lui il était persuadé que les
australopithèques étaient
des singes tueur qu'ils étaient des
chasseurs prolifique
et l'huile ne croyait pas du tout en
l'hypothèse qui était qui avait déjà
pourtant
presque un siècle l'hypothèse selon
laquelle
la majeure partie des
assemblages fossiles
qu'on étudie on était à les parts des
hyènes ça c'est une observation qui a
été fait qui avait été faite par william
buckland
au cours du début du 19e siècle et lui
il n'y croyais pas du tout répond date
lui ils étaient persuadés que non la
haine n'a cumulé pas de restes de deux
d'ossements est de là qu il ne l'est pas
d'ossements elle n'habitait pas dans les
grottes
et c'est ce qu'il a et finit par appeler
le beat de l'aed
accumulateurs noces voilà donc
pas la pluie ils étaient persuadés de ça
et en plus de sa petite nouvelle cerise
sur le gâteau comme il y avait
énormément de reste crânien dans ces
deux assemblages de tanguay de baca par
quatre il a émis l'hypothèse selon
laquelle
australopithèques était en fait un
chasseur spécialisée dans
les deux têtes en fait dans la chasse de
tête et qu'il chassait pour des trophées
et pour des pour des têtes voilà lui
pense et ça
vient par la suite
robert art dray qui lui est écrivain à
l'époque dans les années 60 et qui tombe
sur les écrits et les hypothèses de
raymonde art qui est fasciné par part
par son travail et qui décide de se
rendre en afrique du sud parler
directement à l'écran
et lui adresse il va se mettre en tête
2-2 de diffuser ses idées là du coup il
va écrire des livres il s'agit de livres
apportés grand public pour essayer de de
diffuser un peu ces hypothèses c'est ce
qui va appeler l' hypothèse ici parce
que pour lui l'origine de l'humanité se
retrouve dans la chasse
et
il y a une phrase qui résume très bien
son hypothèse dans dans un de ses livres
qui est l'homme est un prédateur dont
l'instinct naturel et deux tuées avec
une arme voilà ou plus y penser que
l'origine de l'humanité se retrouver
finalement
plutôt dans la violence est plutôt dans
l'origine de la chance et à partir de là
va se va se créer un peu un engouement
autour de cette question a essayé de
savoir essayer de retrouver l'origine
de la chasse et de la consommation de la
viande au sein de la lignée humaine
c'est là toute la question
voilà robert ardres et après robert
ardres est intéressant c'est que son
livre est devenu best seller
et que
park le scénariste de 2001 l'odyssée de
l'espace qui a été par la suite
réalisé par stanley kubrick clark est
tombé sur ce bouquin il l'a lu et
il a été particulièrement frappé par
cette lecture et il a décidé d'en de
l'utiliser pour la scène
d'intro show de 2001 l'odyssée de
l'espace ou vous voyez ce qui semble
être des australopithèques découvrir
les outils notamment
outil en hausse parce qu'ils utilisent
il me semble que c'est un fémur du
virus et plus et qui trouve un d'oslo
d'antilopes et qu'il utilise comme comme
massue ont donc ils découvrent l'ostéo
d'autocars atik culture
dans l'introduction de ce film et ils
l'utilisent pour la violence et pour la
guerre donc voilà donc clark a décidé de
réutiliser cette
cette hypothèse est de la faire figurer
dans
le chef-d'oeuvre de stanley kubrick
voilà qu'il faut savoir que à la suite
de ça à la suite des travaux de de dart
il ya eu beaucoup plus de personnes qui
se sont intéressés à la préhistoire en
afrique en général mais principalement
d'afrique u
et ça va
ça va baudet à la découverte de beaucoup
de sites fossiles notamment dans une
région très restreinte et très
particulière qui se situe à la
quarantaine de kilomètres au nord-ouest
de johannesburg et qui qui qui est
classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco aujourd'hui et qui s'appelle le
cradle of humankind au le berceau de
l'humanité
et donc là bas vont se succéder les
différentes découvertes de nombreux
fossiles d'hominidés magnifique associés
à des fautes très riche en mammifères et
en petits mammifères aussi un pas que
des grands mais aussi de nombreux
rongeurs et petits mammifères et on a
aujourd'hui voilà
une petite diversité au cours du plie
aux pistes scène en afrique australe
avec australopithecus africanus et
paranthropus robustus australopithèques
sediba et aussi des premiers
représentants du genre homo
vous avez également dû suivre peut-être
de nouvelles découvertes majeures qui se
font encore à l'heure actuelle la
dernière en date étant au beau d'aller
dis donc là on sort un peu du cadre du
plie aux pistes celle parce que ça s'est
avéré est d'aider reste assez récent le
300 230 mille ans
ok donc c'est un peu plus récent que ce
qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui mais
c'est pour vous faire comprendre que le
cradle of humankind aujourd'hui continue
à livrer ses secrets voilà tous les ans
on continue de fouiller là bas plusieurs
équipes plusieurs sites et des milliers
de fossiles chaque année qui sort voilà
et en plus de goût d'aller dit on à lui
récemment voilà la
ligne dure si on va dire plutôt voilée
d'occupation plutôt
la présentation au grand public du
squelette enfin sorti de sa brèche du
squelette quasi complet disons complet
de little foot et qui va le s'avérer
être un fossile
majeur pour l'étude de l'évolution
humaine parce que c'est le squelette le
plus vieux et le plus complet
et c'est grâce à la découpe m de tous
ces nouveaux sites
que va arriver l'un des pères fondateurs
disons d'où
l'un des pionniers de l'application de
la taphonomie en préhistoire
charles pub breiz dans les années 80 qui
va lui deux pas du tout être d'accord
avec les idées de raymonde art voilà
tout simplement lui il va pas du tout
être d'accord avec l'idée selon laquelle
tous ces fossiles qu'on retrouve dans
les grottes d'afrique du sud ils ont été
accumulées par australopithèques lui
l'était pas du tout persuadé
qu'il va se mettre en tête de
le prouver ok à savoir également
j'arrive pas à croire que j'ai oublié de
dire ça
mais vous en êtes sûrement rendu compte
avec les dates qui sont affichées ici la
majeure partie une grande partie du
travail de ré banda a eu lieu avant même
la définition du terme taphonomie
l'invention même du terme d'un final
c'est ça qui est super intéressant
il faisait de la taphonomie avant même
de savoir
quand brain arrive au contraire la
taphonomie
en est à ses débuts en préhistoire mais
le terme existent déjà et la définition
existe déjà
et lui d'après lui principalement grâce
à l'étude d'un site majeur d'afrique du
sud qui est le site de soit garanti
il va dès réussir à démontrer que les
hominidés du plie aux plis stoessel donc
y compris australopithecus sépare entre
opus mais aussi les premiers
représentants du genre homo n'était pas
du tout des chasseurs
au contraire il était plutôt
les proies que les prédateurs mais était
plutôt les chasser que les chasseurs
et lui y penser il a réussi en partie à
démontrer grâce
notamment à l'application
de l'état dit donner aux taphonomie
c'est-à-dire pète u2
d'assemblée aird
anta fall be donc en gros essayer de
reproduire que ce soit dans un
écosystème donné ou en laboratoire
essayer de reproduire
des processus taffonneau big stricte
très spécifiques et essayer de
comprendre comment il fonctionne
lui va faire ça il va faire il va par
exemple beaucoup aller traîner dans
l'état dira de yens essaie de comprendre
les habitudes et des carnivores moderne
les observer essayez de de retrouver et
d'étudier des assemblages dont on sait
qu'ils ont été accumulés aujourd'hui par
des léopards
et ensuite par principe d' actualiser
essayer de comparer ces données avec ce
qu'on a dans le passé
c'est pas infaillible comme méthode bien
sur l'actualite mme a ses limites
mais en tout cas
sa force le respect d'avoir poussé cette
réflexion jusqu'au bout quoi la
réflexion de la taphonomie jusqu'au bout
et de se dire ok donc
moi on me dit que les y aide ne peuvent
pas accumuler des ossements je vais
aller sur le terrain et je vais voir et
je vais regarder
et grâce à ça il a réussi à démontrer
que la majeure partie des assemblages
des grottes d'afrique du sud ont été
effectivement accumulées par désactiver
les activités de l'activité des
carnivores et principalement non pas les
y aident des léopards
qui ont cette habitude de tirer leurs
proies
sur les branches des arbres pour les
protéger des autres prédateurs parce que
les léopards se déplace très très bien
dans les arbres ce qui n'est pas
forcément le cas des autres prédateurs
et lui va stocker ses proies dans ces
arbres là
à savoir que certains de ces arbres en
d'afrique du sud sur les terrains
karstique pousse à l'entrée des grottes
pourquoi parce que leurs racines
recherche l'humidité des grottes et en
fait c'est ce qui ce que vous voyez sur
le petit chemin ici c'est ce qui va
créer en fête d'été accumulation
fossiles tout simplement
en mangeant en consommant la proie des
parties de cette pro avons finir par
tomber
dans la grotte proche de la grotte et
ensuite c'est l'érosion l'eau
tout ça qui va faire le travail
voilà et il a en plus découvert voilà
c'était un peu encore la cerise sur le
gâteau pour braids a été de découvrir
c'est
ça a été de découvrir ces traces de
dents de carnivore qui match
parfaitement bien avec les deux caddies
d'inférieur d'un léopard
claque sur
un dock si pital dolly didot donc pour
lui ça a été le coup de grâce un peu la
preuve
indéniable que effectivement
ses hobbies dîner n'était pas des beaufs
chasseurs étaient plutôt des proies et
ils font en fait parti de kiel de
l'accumulation
à l'instar des autres sans thil hop
ils étaient au menu
et c'est également à travers l'étude du
site de soir en soir
36 lisions
envoyées sur un petit car ça c'est à 45
je rappelle 1 40 45 km nord-ouest
johannes bourg pas loin johannesbourg
est juste là bas là ok au soir quand
c'est là c'est aussi grâce à l'étude de
ce matériel que pride va mettre en
évidence la présence d'outils en hausse
des 2,3 millions d'années en afrique du
sud
par l'existence de ces pointes osseuse
voilà donc elle se caractérise par deux
cd petite pointe qui sont en général
donc des skis dos l'ont dont on a
on a du mal à identifier la nature parce
que ben voilà on n'a pas assez
d'éléments diagnostic anatomique pour
essayer de d'identifier précisément de
quel os ça provient des cdo l'on voit
éclats d'os selon
une partie péter et une partie
publie
del ponte poli au bout voilà et ça en
microscopie ça se voit c'est bien donc
on va avoir une série de micro ce
tri-nations donc ça va être
[Musique]
l'usure le jure tout simplement le genre
d'utilisation de l'os
voilà et ça c'est un sport ils ont
d'abord été interprétée par par bob rae
comme étant utilisé probablement pour
comme bâton à fuir pour creuser les
terres litière et avoir accès aux
termites
comme les chimpanzés qui utilisent des
petits pains dits pour aller choper les
fourmis ou les termites et bien la braye
pensé que c'étaient de belles utilisée
pour exploiter les termitières et
accéder aux insectes pour pouvoir les
manger ensuite on a eu une seconde
hypothèse qui a été plutôt
d'être utilisée pour exploiter des
bulbes de plantes par exemple des
racines tous ces trucs là
savoir qu'aujourd'hui le débat il est
pas encore résolu
on ne sait pas à quoi exactement
servez ces outils je ne pense pas que ce
sera possible un jour d'identifier une
tâche spécifique parce que il est fort
probable qu'ils aient été utilisées pour
diverses fonctions tout simplement voilà
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que ces
outils ont été retrouvées grand nombre
en surnombre dans une des couches
de soit 30 du site de france pour lequel
est retrouvée uniquement paranthropus
robustus
voilà et c'est ce qui a conduit brave a
à proposer l'hypothèse selon laquelle
part entre up était
à cette période n'ont pas un bon joueur
de viande mais pluie plutôt un
végétarien spécialisés et qui
utilisaient des outils en os pour
exploiter son environnement végétal
autour de lui
au contraire des premiers représentants
du genre homo qui étaient contemporains
de peindre ce que je rappelle apparition
du genre homo de vienne de lui demander
donc il y avait du genre homo qui
traînait dans le coin
apparemment
donc selon son hypothèse les premiers
représentants du jambon était ou plutôt
porté sur la carne ivory ou au moins ont
consommé un peu
à la différence de parents tantes
ça
c'est aujourd'hui remis en question ou à
leur voix
voilà ça c'est l historique en afrique
du sud petit historique en afrique de
l'est ce rapidement et vous allez voir
que c'est
assez intéressant donc la taphonomie en
afrique de l'est en fait elle va arriver
un peu plus tardivement
mais tardivement
non pas vraiment en gros ce qui est
intéressant d'afrique de l'est c'est que
la préhistoire en fait elle va se
développer très vite à la suite de la
découverte
d'australopithèques en afrique au nom d'
afrique du sud dans les années 20 30 bon
raymond darty
ils travaillent sur ces six là en
afrique du sud en afrique de l'est ça
arrive un peu plus tardivement notamment
sous l'impulsion de la famille et du cou
de dede liquide
qui vont principalement travaillé au
kenya
[Musique]
oui
ils vont faire des dégâts vers très
rapidement des découvertes majeures que
ce soit au kenya et en tanzanie parce
qu'il travaillait également tanzanie où
ils vont découvrir
dans les gorges d'olduvai le produit
reste d'homo habilis
et tout de suite la question de leur
comportement de alimentaire leurs
copains leurs comportements de
subsistance va venir et c'est ce qui va
conduire au développement
de la taphonomie dans les deux régions
simultanément dans les années 80 66 81
voilà c'est ça voilà
donc les premières
premières fouilles corps je le pouvais
et tanzanie
1926 par la famille ed lee qui
les sites ils ont très rapidement été
dans les années 60-70 s'interpréter
comme comme des combats des sites
d'habitat des sites de
partages de nourriture ça c'est grâce
aux travaux du très grand archéologue et
historien américain glee d'isaac
va arriver dans les années 80 bill ford
qui a un peu l'équivalent
est-africains de bab ride
qui lui va remettre en question les
hypothèses de isaac eva eva à voir va
créer et alimenter tout un débat sur les
fonctions réelles
de ces sites est-ce qu'ils étaient
vraiment est ce que c'était vraiment des
sites d'habitat et des sites de partages
de nourriture peut-être pas
et de là ne pas héberger un beau bas qui
va durer jusqu'à aujourd'hui qu'on
appelle le hadji versus scavenging
debate que sa voix la chasse
contre le chah rodage le débat chasse
charognards la question est de savoir et
je vous en ai déjà un peu parlé
au cours du clip liste celle là où on
commence à observer pour la première
fois des traces direct d'exploitation
talibans pour leur viande des traces de
boucherie
est ce qu il
la soeur ou des chars lien
c'est ça la question ou est-ce qu'il se
situait
au sein du réseau trophique
comment toute cette transition
dobby l'idée
au départ végétarien strict à quel
moment s'est effectué ce transition vers
notre statut d'hyper prédateurs
voilà c'est là
c'est là qu'est la question et c'est
autour de ces sites là que s'est
concentré le débat
et du coup au final on remarque que
entre l'afrique de l'est l'afrique du
sud honda un développement
historique
de la taphonomie
similaire qui en fait lié directement à
la montée de ce débat antique versus
qu'avait jean on a dans les années 20 et
les années 40 une idée assez général qui
est que
les premiers pardon que les premiers
en tout cas les eaux midi au pléistocène
était déjà des chasseurs avec des
complexes d'injecter
comporte
complexe
et qui effectuait déjà
une chasse assez développée en groupe et
c'est
dans les années 1980 c'est là où
émergent les premiers trains les
premiers travaux en taphonomie
expérimental en eo taphonomie ça c'est
systématique qui va produire énormément
de données qui sont encore utilisés à
l'heure actuelle et qui va servir à
breil des abymes ford à dire dans les
années 80 ou stop dans des homicides ils
étaient principalement les proies et
dont les prédateurs et si et seulement
s'il avait accès à de la viande c'était
uniquement par
charognards
et ensuite dans les années 2000 alors là
dans les années 2000 c'est une explosion
de l'expérimentation c'est l'explosion
des recherches en eo taphonomie beaucoup
de sujets de thèses et beaucoup de deux
chercheurs se sont rendus sur le terrain
pendant plusieurs mois dans la savane à
essayer d'observer et d'étudier des
assemblages qui ont été accumulées par
des carnivores essayer de comprendre
tout ce à quoi ça sert les années 2000
c'est l'un des hôtes info nomique qui
explosent
et aujourd'hui bas la question elle est
toujours là
il est évident étant donné qu'on a des
traces de boucherie on a des traces de
boucherie dans le registre fossile donc
il est évident
qu'un certain moment un certain moment
donné
c'est au bidil lesquels on ne sait pas
encore au cours du puits bristow scène
il consommer de la viande et la question
demeure comment
charronnage chasse
jardinage actif passif on ne sait pas
mais comme je 10 dans les années 90 il y
avait ce paradigme assez
bien diffuser qui était qu'
à partir de des premières consommation
de viande
aux alentours de 2,6 millions d'années
parce qu'à l'époque on n'avait pas
encore découvert les traces de découpe à
3,4
à partir de larmes à l'apparition donc
2,6 millions d'années apparition de la
consommation de la viande apparition des
premiers représentants du genre homo qui
ont
un cerveau plus gros que leurs
prédécesseurs plus gros
attention tout est relatif au code fois
d'autant plus si on en compte la part a
fini de certains os
donc
et tout ça en fait ça à s'articuler
assez bien 2,6 millions d'années
apparition du genre homo gros cerveau
manger entretien ok la corrélation et se
fait assez facilement
aujourd'hui
c'était plus le cas parce qu'on a des
traces de découpe 3,4 millions d'années
même si elles sont débattues on a aussi
des des outils en pierre même s'ils sont
débattus
qui laisse penser que peut être le genre
homo n'était pas le premier a consommé
de la viande et à chasser hockey
et c'est ce qu'un un papier assez récent
s'est efforcé à démontrer la en 2022
ou andrew barr et ses collègues ont
démontré qu'il n'y a pas de lien
statistique de corrélation statistique
significative entre
l'apparition
d'homo erectus qui est considéré comme
un grand chasseur
imaginaire collectif
premier vrai chasseur
honda d'où l'absence de corrélation
significative entre l'apparition d'homo
erectus d'un registre fossile et
l'accroissement l'augmentation
disons-nous deux traces de boucherie
l'autre c'est à dire l'augmentation de
preuve directe de consommation de viande
donc à ce que tout cela veut dire
on va essayer de le voir un peu plus
quand dans la deuxième partie de la
vidéo quand je vous présenterai tous
les exemples
donc aujourd'hui
lattaf la taphonomie sur les sites
publics stoessel d'afrique j'entends
parce que c'est toujours dans ce cas
d'un conte se situe
aujourd'hui la taphonomie a là un
objectif majeur qui peut être résumée
par ce petit paragraphe
qui avait été écrit par pride dans sa
magnifique monographie de 1990
s'intitule centers incident les
chasseurs ou les chasser aline
traduction africaine caf taphonomie une
introduction à la taphonomie des grottes
africaine
dans ce bouquin dans l'introduction y
résume le but de ce bouquin comme étant
l'analyse des assemblages fossiles dans
le but de savoir comment ces ossements
se sont retrouvés dans la grotte
et d'en tirer des conclusions sur le
comportement des mobilités et sur les
autres animaux avec le lesquels ils ont
interagi ok
super ça
7,7 problème
physique c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on
fait encore à l'heure actuelle or
taphonomie aujourd'hui c'est ce que je
fais moi-même lanta photos mis
aujourd'hui j'applique cette
problématique au site que j'étudie pour
essayer de mieux comprendre les
processus de formation des sites
d'accumulation des ossements
pour mieux comprendre les comportements
des hominidés et mieux comprendre leur
place au sein de l'écosystème hockey